>> All right. We're going
to have a lot of fun today.
We're going to have a lot of
fun in this this session.
We're going to keep
it very engaging,
and which means that
you need to step
up and ask questions and
challenge the speakers,
challenge me.
The way we're going
to run this is
the first 10 minutes I'll speak,
and I'll tell you
a little bit about
my perspective on this,
it's about 10 years
since I started working
on this in this area,
and I want to share
that with you.
A few of you may have heard
this before because
I actually had
a little workshop last week
and I said the same thing.
So, for you guys,
just focus on your work
for now, but anyway,
so 10 minutes I'll
speak and then we'll
give 20 minutes to each speaker
that takes and there
are four speakers that
takes us up to one
hour, 30 minutes.
But, we will not end there
the way everything is set out,
we actually do have
half our budget buffer,
and I'm going to use that to
have a discussion with
all the speakers.
I'll ask them some questions, I
expect you should ask
them some questions,
and we'll make it interactive.
There are five seats here or six,
so there's one extra,
and so we have a surprise guest.
You know who you are
you're here already.
Okay. With that let me begin.
This session for
those of you who are,
who is on Intelligent Edge.
So, if like they
say in the planes,
if you're not in
the right flight,
you probably want to go.
Okay, that joke
didn't work, sorry.
Okay. So, I'm going
to say a few things about
my own personal journey on this.
So, before I say this has
been hammered into you,
I think by now,
but I want to take this
time to do it as well.
Microsoft Azure is large,
it's very, very big,
it's very complex serving
as these numbers indicate.
There are so many moving parts
as the network is massive,
33,000 plus miles of lit
fiber across our WANs,
more than 100,000 miles of
fiber inside our data centers.
Millions of components,
millions of servers,
all interconnected
packets flowing
from one to another point.
It's an engineering
marvel in some sense.
It's plotted scale, it's huge,
and as you think about research,
you can start to start to
see that we need discipline,
a lot of discipline in
designing such systems,
and we have to be
very careful because
if anybody is going to
take dependency on us,
on the Cloud, we better damn
well stay up all the time.
Right? That's why people
work very hard and
they worry about anything
breaking at any given
point anyway.
So, it's a large,
large, large system.
In teams or in terms of
the economics of it,
you also heard Mark talked
a little bit about it,
I had these numbers too, so I
want to share them
with you as well,
in FY18, $23 billion revenue,
that's a significant amount
and it's going
fast up 89 percent growth,
but I have these numbers
up from my FY17.
I wanted to update it
this morning, but I couldn't,
but you can see the numbers
how fast the growth is happening.
We can't build fast
enough, that's the deal.
There are so many customers,
we can't build fast enough.
In fact, we have to slow down
to avoid over promising,
but from a research that actually
makes an interesting problem too,
I mean if the Cloud
is could be statistically
multiplexed,
we could actually use
the service again.
So, there's a lot of researchers
in Microsoft and my group,
and those are groups
that do that,
and so you can also
see from this number,
90 percent of the biggest,
largest companies in
the world depend on it.
So, it's all good.
So, that sets
the stage for things.
All right. So, how did
this thing start for me?
In 2000, I have
the right date, yeah.
In 2008, I invited
Satya from CMU,
many of you might know him,
to come to Mark's research
in building 99,
and we had a one-day
brainstorming session
on what does it mean to
what is going to happen after
Cloud of things changed too.
In fact, I would challenge
you to think like that too,
20 years from now, what is
the world going to look like?
Right? So, that's what
we were talking about,
and then out of their discussion,
gave out the speech paper.
This is the paper that
people started
Southsiders Cloudlets,
and we published this paper.
Initial thoughts,
you look back at it,
you think, okay, well, we
could do things a
little differently.
Then, this is the first article
that came out in December 13,
2009, which says, "How the
Cloudlet Will Beat the Cloud."
This is the Edge,
so think of it as
the Edge, the Intelligent Edge.
If you'd look at
the citation count,
which I just did a while ago,
you can see a paper is
very heavily cited.
So, lot of people have read it,
are working on it,
and a publishing on it.
Now, in the Faculty
Summit of 2009,
I did a demo of Edge Networking,
and the demo was the actual
what is now the Skype Translator.
We literally,
someone I was sitting
here, Walter was with me,
and we offloaded
this translation capability
to the Edge on
a phone and then he was
talking in Spanish,
I was talking in English, and we
were doing this in real time,
and then we publish
the paper for
the programming model for
that of how how
programmers will do that,
and that too has been cited
quite a bit since then.
Okay. So, then, I had
this opportunity,
we have in Microsoft Research,
we have this thing
called the DTR or
Disruptive Technology
Review where
researchers can go every year,
happens every year,
now starting to
happen every two years,
but can go and talk to
the CEO and the entire SLT,
they come into the building 99,
and tell them about
what trends or
what things we think can
either disrupt us or we can
do to disrupt the industry.
So, in that, I actually presented
this, I presented this.
If you look at this picture,
you will see discuss Maui
know that's the paper
that was referring to,
but really this is the Edge
right, and this is the Cloud.
One of the things I said
at that thing this slide
is from that time was that hey,
you have this wireless things,
you have access points,
you've got the switches,
and here right next to the switch
is your Edge node that
was my we know it,
and then we talked about it.
But, I made a mistake,
Steve Ballmer who was
the CEO asked me, "Okay,
Victor, what do you
think we should do
differently today?"
He didn't ask me
about the future,
he asked me, "What do you
want me to do today?"
That was a question
I did not expect,
the shame on me now,
I look back at my life,
and think that was him.
But, think about it,
as researchers we always focused,
we always saying, "Oh,
we could do this.
We could do this.
Well, has the CEO asking
me what do you want me
to change right now,
and I stumbled a little bit,
and so told him
speech recognition,
I think I said, the speech
translation or something.
There was an EVP there and
he didn't buy into it,
he said, "Not needed," and
in some sense he's right.
I mean, we have all this stuff
going in the Cloud and it works,
but so that was sort
of didn't really work.
So, I went back and
I kept working on this stuff,
I really believed it,
and then I had
another chance in 2014,
actually there was for 2013,
but we did it on 2014.
I had another chance
in front of the SLT,
but this time I took
the problem on differently.
I wanted to make the case
that look in the Cloud,
we sell storage and
we sell computes.
I want to sell latency.
Latency is the hard thing
because you don't have
control many of it,
you don't control the Internet.
So, then, logically,
will immediately says,
"Well, one thing is to make many,
many data centers
around the world,
and that's not
financially viable."
So, the other is, hey, let's
put lots of edges
around the world.
Right? So, that was thing.
I showed him this video,
which I want to show you.
I do have a point
after all of this,
so that's spared me for a second.
So, would you watch this video
carefully and tell
me what you see.
So, there are
seven people walking,
there's a camera that's taking,
this is the original video.
Now, we're going to do
face recognition on
it with 2-5-millisecond
latency on the Edge,
and you should see that.
Then, we can run
the same program.
This is four years ago,
so things are better now with 75,
85, and the reason we use 75,
85 was because LTE rule
of thumb is about
70-millisecond latency.
What did you see
different in the two?
Can anybody, people who've
seen it don't please say,
but did anybody see anything
different in this? Come on.
>> Someone has her hands
up in the first,
but not on the second.
>> It wasn't?
>> Something has her hands
up in the first slide,
but not on the second.
>> Okay, that's an observation.
Anybody else would
like to play the game?
Yeah, that's true too.
I'll do it one more
time. Why do worse?
So, there's the original video,
then there is video with
face recognition
five, and it's five,
as many offloading five
milliseconds away,
and then there is 70,
75 milliseconds away afterwards.
So, that's the first one,
and now here's the second
one with the LTE latencies.
The DOC is for,
that's exactly right,
there were seven people,
seven were recognized,
in the second case,
there were only four.
That's a serious problem,
that's a functionality problem,
imagine that something like
that somebody else does,
and you're you're actually
losing serious
functionality there.
You can't do it, the system can't
do it, right? It's
not fast enough.
So, this is what I
showed, I actually showed
a bunch of other things too
and I'll show you another one,
which actually you may catch,
and this is gaming,
fast action gaming
that was happening.
So, Advada here, so
he's playing this game,
he's a top notch gamer and he
plays the game 35 seconds,
30 millisecond latency, and
40 millisecond latency.
Now, in this particular video
all you're seeing is I just point
out because you really
don't have time here,
is that when he clicks,
there's lag between
the click and what he sees.
So, now, if you
transmit on just to
a more serious game where he's
fighting somebody and shooting,
what do you see is that as
we increase the latency,
he goes from killing everybody
and winning the game to
a point where he gets shot all
the time because he reacts,
but his reaction time is slow,
and the game is still playing,
and boom he loses the game.
So, that's not going to work.
So, if you do seek Cloud gaming,
it's not going to work
unless you master latency,
so I'm going to
just move forward.
So, I made this prediction
after that in the DDR.
I said the world is now moving
in this direction, okay?
So, you got this mega Clouds,
you got to have
a disaggregated Cloud.
You're not going to
be able to sustain
mega Clouds for various reasons.
It was the prediction
was made by 2020,
everything's going to
look very different.
All right. I was actually
when I made this talk,
I had actually gone through
many examples of what
are the different
advantages of Edge.
You can read this and
I'm going to belabored
point because you're going
hear more from people here.
But, this was not just
a prediction made,
this was systems built
showed this was happening.
So, what happened
after that meeting is,
this is just before
Satya became the CEO,
Steve Ballmer asked me how
much it's going to cost,
and Satya who is in
the audience said,
"$380 million for us to do
this," and Steve
said, "Do it, do it."
I was shocked. I won,
well, not really it's
one thing to get senior
management to agree.
It's another thing
to get the people
who actually do
the stuff to bring,
and that's where
everything gets stuck.
So, in the meantime,
the world was evolving too.
I mean, Satya had gone
and created his own.
He's done tremendous
work since then.
He's true believer there.
Then, I had seen the world
moving out in different
directions as well.
A lot at this
conference was created,
I was part of that, and
the full consortium was created.
By the way, I hate the word fog,
also think they ripped
off many of the things
we did and just call it
fog but that's okay,
and actually you have proof
of that, but that's not.
So, then, but I was still not
happy because where's the money?
Where's the money? We
needed a killer app.
So, then we had this observation,
it wasn't attune sabbatical
and decides which didn't happen.
There are cameras everywhere,
they have millions of
cameras everywhere.
They're streaming video,
nobody's looking at that.
Computer vision and AI will
becoming big, systems were good.
So, then, we started
working for four years.
We have worked on
video analytics trying to show,
and yes I still believe
there's a lot of money here,
and I still believe this
is the Edge story
from my perspective,
and we did some good stuff here.
We actually want to national
awards because of the
work we did here.
Then, something
interesting happened.
I was using this work,
yeah, Microsoft
talking to all my colleagues,
and then in December of 2016,
this guy he's a VC,
if you don't know him, he's
a well known VC from
Silicon Valley.
He gave a talk entitled
The Death of Cloud.
In that talk, he basically
made the point for Intelligent
Edge, he talked about AI,
he talked about doing
the latency thing,
pretty much very, very
similar to what we had
been talking about here.
But, he was outside,
it was in the VC,
he funds companies and
things of that nature,
boom, it became a big thing.
In the meantime, I have
great respect for our CEO,
and the reason I have a lot
of respect for Satya is,
well, he has empathy
and I like that,
but another thing is
he's a smart guy.
He has his finger
on the pulse of what is
happening in the world,
and he watches it,
he observes it,
he talks to it,
and then he makes decisions.
So, he's along, he
knows we're doing this,
but then he starts to see this,
and then he goes out and
says Intelligent Edge,
we're going, we're all in.
Microsoft is all in
Intelligent Edge.
It's not just the Cloud story,
it's Intelligent Edge story.
Now, things start to move in
a really, really big way.
This is what he
says in Build 2017,
but he had started
seeing this already
as you can imagine.
In the meantime, a lot
of research reports
start to come up, Edge is it.
Edge is going to be the thing,
and this is just one example
of one of those reports.
There are many who
will came out about how the
Edge will eat the Cloud.
I actually don't believe that at
all and we will bring
that up in the panel.
Then, of course, you start
to see news articles,
you start to see people getting
excited, there's so many,
I just put some samples here
just to say that all these,
it was becoming a big thing.
All right. Then,
another big thing happen.
So, Microsoft announces that
we're going to invest
five billion dollars in IoT,
and in the text,
it talks about
the Intelligent Edge as
one of the key components
for the five-billion-dollar
investment.
Now, things are hot, really hot,
you've got $110 billion
company saying that
we're going to start investing
in this, that's significant.
Now, people are starting
to move pretty hard.
You're going to start hearing
Ajmandd, he's one
of our speakers,
and it's going to fill in a lot
of the gaps that
I'm leaving here.
But, I'm just taking we're
talking about it from
my perspective how exciting
things are getting for me.
Then, a couple of days ago,
I was piece share of this
symposium on Edge computing.
I'm sitting there and
listening to the papers.
If we had all these
paper discussions
to figure out which
papers to accept.
I start to see papers in
all these different areas,
but Edge related papers.
This is really exciting now.
So, you've got businesses
starting to say, "This is big."
You got the VC community saying,
"We are ready to invest."
You got researchers pointing
out all the different issues,
which is going to keep them
working for several years,
and these problems and
their solutions are quite
innovative if you think about it.
You have something now.
It is no longer a fad.
There's nothing of that.
This is something very
concrete because these problems
will get solved.
For example, one of
the problems that still exists
is availability in SLAs.
In Clouds we have SLAs,
so if you depend on something,
you say it'll be there.
When you introduce Edge,
what's the SLA? What's
the availability?
Lot of papers on that area
and since this early
work there were
all these holes that we
didn't accept all of them
but you can start to see this.
You saw things like management.
When you have imagine that
you've got not just one Edge.
Now, you got tens of
thousands of Edge,
way more than the Cloud. How
you're going to manage it?
Who's going to own the Edge?
Is it going to be like
the companies like
Microsoft or is it
going to be a
federated model where
somebody else on the
Edge? You may not know.
So, as you think about
all the stuff you think,
what about privacy?
What about security? In Cloud,
we can offer you
some level of security
because we kept everything
in lock and key.
Now, the Edge is sitting on
your premise, somebody can come,
take out a disk, copy it,
put it back, who
knows what happened?
Real serious problems come up.
So, my final thoughts here
are there is a paradigm shift
that is happening,
and it is going to be
very big, I predict.
I just looked at
some report and it
says this year is
the year of AI on Edge.
I didn't focus too much on
the intelligent part of it,
I leave the speakers to do.
With that, we started
this thank you,
and then we will start the thing
by having four speakers.
I'm really excited to have them.
Is Mung here?
Yeah, come on over,
we're going to speak
in this order.
So, let me introduce you to Mung.
Many of you might know him.
He was actually the director and
investor of the Edge Lab
in Princeton so.
>> Well, thank you
Victor very much.
What a pleasure to be here,
thanks for the invitation
and as Victor said
that my day job is
the Dean of College of
Engineering at Purdue
now since a year ago,
but in my nighttime and
vacation and weekend
is research in networking
and continue to do that.
Part of that is still
a visiting appointment
to a direct Edge Lab at
Princeton and the other is
participating in
the open forum consortium.
Victor and I, we have
debates about the use
of English words like
fog or edge and I'm
going to just brush that
aside for the next 15 minutes
here since I lost
five minutes trying to
get Mac and Microsoft
to work together,
I'll try to be brief here.
The main messages is on
network decomposition.
What is that?
While the job, I
like the CEO's job,
you've got a great one
and Victor is to sort of
decide who does what at
what time scale and how to
glue them back together.
So, it's not just
allocating the resources,
but also allocating
the functions.
How each function is
carried out it is less of
a concern for
the decomposition itself.
Now, there is the vertical
decomposition layering as
a fundamental concept
in networking to
modularize a complex
interacting system.
Layering can be mathematically
understood as optimisation
decompensation,
both reverse engineering and
also a design synthesis
for engineering.
For example, Kumar
was the one who gave
me and many in the community
a lot of inspiration back.
This is 15 plus years ago also
on the notion of
architecture and thinking
about layering that way.
Now, this subject that
Victor is putting together,
the panel this morning
on Intelligent edge now,
I think of the Cloud and
Edge/Fog as a horizontal
decomposition.
All the architectures
in some sense
are there to be a little
philosophical if
you will and then
to support a range of
practical applications.
For example, in 1948,
the Shannon Source-Channel
Separation is
an architectural principle and
very crisply stated
mathematically as well,
and that principle
in architecture
further led to the applications
of digital communications.
When Sir Bob Kahn did
the TCP/IP published in
74 and that is
an architectural design,
and that led to
the vertical applications
in the Internet and the web.
Then the Edge and Fog,
my biggest hope is
that it will continue
to be worked on by the community
from industry and
academia around the world
and arise these
architectural foundations
for applications such as IoT
and 5G or Dispersive AIs.
So, I'm going to abbreviate
my personal journey
much shorter here.
Back about a decade ago,
I started the Princeton Edge Lab.
Back then, I got two
interesting question one is,
one large fortune 500 company
told me the word edge has been,
not Microsoft, has
been trademarked.
So, I have to stop using
the word Edge Lab,
and the Princeton lawyer
wrote something
back and then never heard
anything from them again.
The other is that people
told me a moment,
"Well I like it and stuff
but you on the wrong side,
everything will move
away from the Edge.
Edge will be dumb.
Have you heard of
the word Cloud?"
Distributing functions
whether it's computation,
storage or computing or
control to the Edge.
Then, back to three years ago,
I was a founding member of
the OpenFog consortium.
Now, one could ask,
"Why did you not
like the word Edge
anymore after few years?"
I say, "Well, not really.
I don't particular care
about English word,"
and I know that for
example Victor thinks that Fog is
a very vague foggy word
and why don't we just
keep using the word Edge.
But, if there is an industry
including Microsoft, Cisco,
Intel and quite a few others
want to get together use a term,
I say, "That's fine with me too."
Decomposing functions along
this C-2-Things Continuum,
Cloud-2-Things Continuum.
So, this is sort of wrong
picture to show but let me
first tell you what is perhaps
useful about it first.
Now, on the one side
you've got the Cloud,
on this other side you got,
that looks like a fog or mist
or whatever you call it.
Now, the interesting point
is that you need both.
Now, Peter Levin's
provocative essay
to say the death of Cloud,
might be exaggerating
to make a point.
I don't see the death of Cloud,
I see the rise of the Edge and
Fog and depending on
what you want to do.
What belongs to Caesar
goes to Caesar,
what belongs to God goes to God.
Now, this picture is
however also wrong
because it is not a dichotomy,
it is a continuum.
There is no digital sort
of boundary to say,
"Yes," it's a choice
between either and or.
Furthermore, the pendulum
swings back and forth.
The time scale is
about 15-20 years or so.
So, some argue that there's
nothing new under the sun
then they were merrily swinging
the pendulum every
two decades or so.
Whether this NSF, or industry,
or a PhD thesis and perhaps
it is not that cynical.
I think every swing brings
new ideas driven by
new context too.
But, it is true that the rise
of the Cloud and then now there's
the rise of the Edge and Fog
then big believer just
like Victor myself.
But I won't be surprised that
10 50 years later at
Microsoft Faculty Summit,
whatever 2034, people will say,
"Oh, this Edge thing
is just so like 2028."
We should go centralization,
we should look at economy of
scale and somebody in
the audience will say,
"I vaguely remember when I
was young there's something
called the Cloud."
So, this pendulum will keep
swinging and that is fine.
There are many topics as Victor
is saying one could
talk about it in Edge,
Intelligence Edge
or Fog including
I think the economic side
of it is very important.
How do you incentivize?
The security privacy is
important but let
me just focus next
10 minutes particularly on
the Dispersive AI as one of the,
in my mind, three main
pillars software
application verticals.
So, here you again,
want to leverage
the fact that you
got latency on your side.
Latency in two ways.
First, you can do Edge analytics
or stream or mining with
the live streaming
of data coming to
you and you can understand
it right here right now.
The other is you dare to put in
some feedback control loop
because you know
that latency and
perhaps more importantly jitter
is much more under control.
Is small and almost
deterministic latency so
you can run control loops
in cyber-physical systems.
Now, you got to decompose
the machine-learning computation
and control into
disparate components and
then they will be working
either collectively or
jointly and you can think
about pre-positioning and so on.
So, this is about a year ago,
we did a demo of
one particular platform
that we did at Princeton.
Think of this as
a MapReduce for Edge or Fog
and what you want to do is
to look at
opportunities to frame.
How would you decompose
machine-learning
computations in order
to map to this new substrate?
So, I'm going to fly
through some slides here
but the typical chart
you want to see,
this is just a toy example,
last year is to say, "Well,
between one extreme end
completely on the device,
the other extreme end
completely on the Cloud,
what happens in between?"
While there's a trade-off between
what's done locally and what
is coordinated
communicated globally,
you want this summation
to be smaller than
either end and that's
a little comparison between
what we did in Spark.
The unique feature
really is that,
you got an Edge or Fog to size.
On the challenging side,
there's heterogeneity
unlike the Cloud,
you don't have racks
of servers that run on
the same OS and similar
hardware capabilities.
You've got variability
even volatility
because unlike a rack of servers,
these little things they
move perhaps and they
may not always be
available and you got constraints
bandwidth for sure and maybe
even battery constraints.
But on the other hand,
you also got the nice things such
as physical proximity to
sensors and actuators.
So, the challenge is to
take care of heterogeneity,
variability and
constraints and take
advantage of the proximity.
Now, how would you decompose
a job whether it's
counting words in a file
or slightly more
interesting let's say,
run a least squares for example.
One of the simplest things
you can think of.
If you run a large-scale
least squares
as embedded in the loop
of some particular optimization
for machine learning,
you know how to do
that by decomposing
the job into parallel
computation on a rack of
servers very well but
how would you decompose
that job over a very
different substrate?
The add Fox substrate.
So, here are two toy
examples to illustrate
this notion of decomposing
the computation over
this kind of substrate.
One is about Drone Camera work
with Aakanksha and
Shirley in my lab.
So, imagine now in this
particular application topic
you've got the outdoor,
say a sports event like
the FIFA World Cup soccer,
and people have thought about
using cameras over
cross wires for example,
but if you use drones to
capture and to transmit,
what would happen?
So, here is one way to
look at the choices
are of architecture.
On the one end, you can
make everything locally
done but then you lose
the collaboration.
You may miss some of
the important scenes in the
coverage and you may have to
reduce the video transmission
right out of those drones.
On the other hand,
you have a fully
centralized version of it
and you have to make
decisions centrally.
Now, this could be
the Azure Cloud way out there or
it could be even a big
server on the ground.
That big server to
all the little drones
feels like the Cloud.
It's just like a little rock
to us may feel like
a mountain to the ends.
But you're going to suffer
the round-trip time limits.
So, the ability to coordinate in
real time in response to
game dynamics will be limited.
So, here is one
particular decomposition,
I'm not arguing,
this is the best
the decomposition
even for this Application,
but you see that the drones
form little Fog network
among themselves.
They would take care of
the following functions;
trajectory planning and
collision avoidance,
and then there is
a little central coordinator for
next target location optimisation
and deciding which drone
should be doing what.
So, you've got eight drones,
let's say, up in the air.
Which of those should help you to
cover the scenes and which should
help you to relay
the video streams?
So, that will be done
with coordination.
So, there is
a Steel Controller up
there and then you've got
the sensors on the boss
and the players,
and then you got the, let's say,
eight or whatever number
of drones up in the air.
So the drones now,
they got to decide to cover,
they got to decide to transmit,
and you can do
other fancy things,
3D rendering and so on,
if you want to do
that in real time.
There is actually a trade-off
between maximizing
Coverage and
maximizing Throughput,
and you only got
that many drones.
So for each drone,
should that drone
help with Coverage or
should that help with relaying
and enhancing Throughput.
It turns out you can run a
integer programming
joint optimization
and there are
some heuristics will allow
you to solve it very fast,
even though not truly optimally.
Just a little chart
to show what we did,
I guess illegally on the field on
Sunday mornings near Princeton,
I shouldn't say that.
Probably legally,
flying the drones and
you look at the
trade-off over there.
In this particular case,
it turns out that if
you've got eight drones,
follow them to focus on coverage,
follow them to focus on,
streaming is the best.
Now which is Covering?
Which is streaming?
That depends on
the real time situation
that is actually coordinated
by the Cloud, if it will.
So, the message here is not
about the Application per se.
We can go into that detail
on another day,
but to say if you
want to coordinate
group of drones working
with each other,
certain functions can be done
by themselves on the drones and
others should be done on
the ground with a little server.
So, the second
quick illustrative example
is something that we were
doing it last month,
it's still ongoing, it's
some preliminary results
here to share.
It's about ARVR and
particularly the technical
problem of Object placement,
so that they don't
block important things,
and don't confuse the viewer,
and we want to personalize
the placement challenge.
The question is, where do you
learn about the
personal preferences?
And where does
the learning happen?
By the way, that is actually
the Princeton Edge lab outside in
the corridor over
there and those are
the holograms in that experiment.
So again, the main message
is that there's
a variety of choices in
network decomposition here.
During the policy learning phase,
there is a user,
there's an agent,
and the agent we're trying
to mimic the user and
learn what is
the personal preference
of overlapping and a foreground,
background placement
of the holograms.
Then there is, secondly,
a policy execution phase
after you've gone through
the learning phase.
In both phases you
can either have
a little server there or you
can have the end device,
in this case, the AR set
to do the computation.
What we found in
this particular case is
a trade-off whereby the policy is
learned with the
computation primarily on
the little server next
to these AR devices,
but then in execution,
the parameter choices of
the learned policy is
done in real time.
That's not again surprising
trade-off but is one that worked,
and this is a quick video,
it's one minute, I'll probably
skip in a few seconds.
On the left-hand side
is the user,
on the right-hand side
is the agent.
This is during
the learning phase.
You want to learn
the policy before
you execute the
policy in real time
and it shows how
the right-hand side agent is
learning quite efficiently,
based on what the user is doing.
To start it out,
if you still remember,
15 seconds ago.
Way off, whether
the hologram should be
placed in covering
the real object
or behind the real object,
or where it should be but
within 10-15 iterations,
it learned very fast.
Let me just skip to
the next slide there.
So, one way to visualize that
the learning processes is
after a few demos, basically,
all those little dots
are the decisions
by the agent to learning
the user preference and
personalized placement,
and that they all aggregate
to the correct place.
Now, what is
interesting is that if
you don't use
State-Space reduction,
then even after many more rounds,
you still are all
over the places.
On the left-hand side is
you do use State-Space reduction,
right hand side is you do use
it and you can clearly
see the benefits.
Now, the State-Space reduction is
carried out not on the AR
themselves but on
the little server.
So again, the main message there
is not it about AR placement,
personalisation is that there's
a choice of where do you
carry out the learning?
One possibility is let the policy
stay in the Cloud, if you will,
and let the actual parameter
and execution stay
on the end devices.
So, the overall question
really is, where,
as in the horizontal
decomposition,
where do you place a function?
We haven't even got to
the point of where do
you place the data?
What is the interface among
these modules over there?
So, my last slide is just to
highlight what is,
perhaps obvious,
on why is it even interesting
to explore that today?
I think of the acronym scale.
I learned that if
you want to write
a winning NSF
proposal you have to
come up with good acronym.
Although this was refuted by
Jim Crosby last night to me,
that it is not
a necessary condition.
But I guess it doesn't hurt.
So, S is the potential
advantage on security.
The less distance it traverses,
more privacy is
potentially protected.
One could argue the
other way, to say, "Wow,
these little things
trusting them with
more and more functions but
they are easier to hack into",
and their update is
not done properly.
Cognition is,
because you are much
closer to the end
user and ambiance,
you have a better understanding
of user-centric objective.
Agility just refers to the fact
that generally speaking,
you go into the Cloud,
the core Network of LT and so on.
You go through 3GPP and it takes
forever to update and change,
whereas if you rely
on that end devices,
the agile development
process is much faster.
Latency, we mentioned, as
the number one reason,
as Victor also highlighted that
people think about why do I even
care and need anything
other than the Cloud.
Efficiency is
actually interesting.
There's the D to D efficiency.
Device talking to device,
but then there's also
the device for device,
D for D efficiency,
that because you have
proximal distance,
you can authorize the idle
resources connectivity,
computation and so on
that are in physical
proximity to each other.
So, S-C-A-L-E these are
the reasons I think of
why Network decomposition,
horizontally closer to
the user's Edge/Fog
is becoming ever so more
interesting. Thanks.
>> Okay. So, we can ask
one question, if there's one.
We'll have, hopefully, that
is sometimes after the panel.
But in the mean time, somebody
wants to ask a question?
>> You can ask the question
and I'll answer.
>> I have a bunch of
questions for you.
We'll do it when we do the panel.
>> All right.
>> Thank you. Yeah. So, great
pleasure to introduce
Mark Kishore Ramachandran.
He actually goes by
the name Kishore
and then for those
of you who are from India
know Kishore Kumar Kishore,
anyway so, my jokes are so flat.
Okay. So anyway, so he got
his PhD from University
of Wisconsin, Madison.
He is now a professor
at Georgia Tech.
He's interests are in
parallel distributed systems
and Edge, as you can see.
He's been working on
this space for a while.
He's quite passionate about
providing connectivity and
services in the rural areas.
I actually was there in one
of the NSF workshops he
had actually organized with
Aneesh, and quite fascinating.
With that, please take it away.
>> Well, I mean,
there is this debate
that Victor started
with Edge versus Fog,
but let me ask you a quiz,
how many of you know
Victor's real first name?
Any of you who knows?
Among, what's
the name, do you know?
Paramvir is real first name
and it means supreme hero.
It sort of loose- and you should
ask him during the panel.
During the panel part
asked him how did
he got the name, Victor.
So, I think Mung and Victor,
both of them gave a nice segue
to what I'm going to talk about,
and the title of my talk
is Elevating the Edge to
be a Peer of the Cloud.
So, that's the spiel that
I'm going to talk about.
Of course I wouldn't be
standing here but for
all my students who've
done all the work that
I'm going to highlight
a little bit in describing
what we're doing.
So, I think IoT
and the scale of applications
that run on the IoT,
all of these are things that
you all are familiar with
and the key thing that
Mung and Victor
pointed out is that,
future applications on
the IoT infrastructure
is going to have
this characteristic of
sensing, processing,
and actuating
which means that
latency becomes really
critical in going from
sensing to actuation.
Cloud computing as we know it is
great for throughput
oriented application,
but not latency
sensitive applications.
There are also
other considerations
regulatory considerations
and backhaul bandwidth
and so on.
All of these may argue for moving
the computations away
from the Cloud and
that's where Fog/Edge Computing
comes in and the rules as Mung
pointed out it's
really a hierarchy of
devices all the way from
the client devices,
to routers, to servers,
all the way to the Cloud.
So, that's the continuum
that exists in this world.
Now, what I want to
emphasize is the fact that
today Edge computing as
we know it is a slave
of the Cloud.
There are lots of very
interesting platform
that had been designed,
Arjmand is going to talk
about IoT Azure Edge,
Cisco has its own IoX platform,
but all of these require
that the coordination is
coming from the Cloud
and there was a good example
that Mung already pointed
out in terms of drones,
coordinating with one another.
So, that's the idea
behind wanting
to elevate the Edge
to be at the peer to
the Cloud and today actually
we are beholden to the Cloud
because if I want to send
a text message to Arjmand,
I have to go to the Cloud
and come back to him, right?
So, that just doesn't
seem right to us.
So, vision for the future is
that the Edge is going to become
a peer of the Cloud and there's
prior art that Victor
already pointed out,
Cloudlets and MAUI and
all of them are trying
to do the following,
which is sort of take
computations from the air
as a client devices,
and launch it onto the
server that is nearby,
but in the limit what
we want to do is,
make the Edge autonomous,
even if it is disconnected
from the Cloud.
I can give lots of reasons
why this might be
a good thing because the
interacting entities if you
think self-connected you
know connected vehicles
applications and so on,
there is lot of things
that need to happen
horizontally among
the Edge nodes.
Even more importantly,
if you think
about disaster recovery
and things like that,
they may not even have kind
of connection to the Cloud,
and in that case,
the drone example was
a great one, right?
So, if I have
the ability to connect
to even if I have
disconnections among them,
if I have the ability
to connect to somebody,
I can actually communicate and
then eventually my information
will get passed on to the others
and we can have
a happy situation.
So, these are motivating
reasons why you may want to
elevate the Edge to be
a peer of the Cloud.
But there are lots of
challenges making this happen.
First of all, as the Cloud
as we know it today,
is so powerful mainly because of
all the infrastructure
that has gone into it.
Right? There is a
no programming models,
storage abstractions,
pub/sub systems and so on
that make it a powerful
development engine for rapidly
prototyping applications.
Now we have geo-distributed
Edge nodes and we
want to provide
the same sort of ability
for rapidly prototyping
applications.
And what that means is that,
we need powerful frameworks,
akin to the Cloud to be
available at the Edge.
Yesterday Albert Greenberg was
emphasizing the need for
making sure that
recovery is important,
which means that when you
have distributed data,
then you have to worry
about replication
in a geo-distributed fashion
so that you can
avoid correlated failures that
might happen in
a particular neighborhood.
So, those are important
and when you do that,
then there is the latency and
consistency trade-offs
that comes about, right?
So, those are things that
you have to worry about.
As they are similar to the Cloud,
we want the same sort
of elasticity of
deploying application
components rapidly and
the fact that you might have
the same IoT infrastructure,
that is simultaneously
being used by
multiple applications means that
you have to have worry
about multi-tenancy.
All of these are issues
that are challenging.
In the remaining time,
what I'm going to do is you
know lots of people are
working on interesting
areas related to
these topics and I'm
going to give you
a little bit of a sort
of a bird's eye view
into some of our own thoughts
on addressing some
of these challenges.
So, I'll talk about
a programming model
that goes across the continuum
between- in some sense
enabling application
similar to what Mung
was talking about in
being able to share
information across
the Edge as well as
vertically with a Cloud
and then how do you do
Geo-distributed data replication.
Then also motivate
some example applications
that might use autonomous Edge.
So, that's the thing
that I want to do in
the last in the next
10 minutes or so.
But obviously I cannot do
full justice for
that and I invite
you to talk to me
or look at some of these
publications that we have here.
So, first let me talk about
the Geo-distributed
programming model.
The idea is that you
have sensors that
might be generating
data and the application
itself will be
a dataflow graph that you can
represent it as a dataflow graph,
and what you wanna do is Victor
talked about what
are the SLAs, right?
SLAs in these kinds of
applications tend to be latency.
So, given the latency
properties of
the application components
and interaction among them,
then you can decide how to
place them in the continuum,
both horizontally as well as
vertically in this continuum.
So that's part of what
this foglets distributed
programming model does is,
is respecting the
application properties,
it places the application
components in
the hierarchy in the continuum.
But that's not a one-time thing
because you can have
sensors moving,
and if sensors move then
the Fog node that used
to be processing may
not be the appropriate one
to continue the processing.
Which means that you have to
migrate the application component
to a node that is
close to where
the production of data is.
So, that transparent
state migration
is part of foglets
programming model as well,
and then multi-tenancy is
something that I
already mentioned.
So, once you migrate
something to a different Fog
node but you've left
some breadcrumbs over here,
and those breadcrumbs
are rebrought
over in order to continue
the computation.
That's part of
the programming model
in terms of transparently
worrying about
moving both the
computation as well as
the state of those
distributed computation,
that's what this foglets
programming model gives you,
and if you're interested
in that please look at
this publication and I'll
be happy to talk to
you also about that.
The second thing that
I want to mention is
the second project relates to
the recovery aspect of it.
So, when you have data
that is very important,
then you want to make sure
that the data doesn't go
away when there is
failures, right?
So, the latency is
also a consideration.
So, what we want to do is,
we want to replicate
the data in order
to worry about
recovery properties.
So, that's okay, go ahead
and replicate it in
a particular way so
that I can make sure that
the latency that is
important is preserved.
But if I do this, what's going
to happen is if there is
a correlated failure that
all of the data is
lost, therefore,
what I might want to do is
I might want to replicate
the data far away from
the current location of where
the data is being
generated so that I can
have a resiliency and
recovery properties,
but that results in poor latency.
So, there is this consistency
and latency trade-off
that exists.
When you think about some of
these frameworks that are
available in the Cloud,
what it'll let you do
is it will say, "Well,
we're going to give you
eventual consistency,
that's all we're
going to give you.
If you care about
strong consistency,
you look at it in
the application.
If there was a violation
of strong consistency
you have to take corrective
actions in the application."
That to me is not
very satisfying.
So, one of the things that
my students came up with
this idea of a context
of interest.
So, the context of interest
says that this is a context in
which I want very
strong guarantees in the data.
Meaning, that I want to know that
anything that I read is
most up-to-date value, right?
So, that's a strong consistency
is being provided in
the context of interest.
But from the point of view
avoiding correlated failures,
what we're going to do is,
we're going to also replicate
it in a faraway node,
but we don't give you
strong guarantees on that,
so we give you eventual
consistency for that.
So, that's the idea behind
this FogStore work, and again,
only a bird's eye view of
the details in
that paper but if you're
interested in that you
can look at this paper.
So, that's the second
thing that is looking
at the latency properties.
The third thing is
the fact that you have
Fog resources and alluded to this
that the resources are
not multiple racks.
You have a limited amount of
resources and you are having
applications that are continuously
generating data 24-7.
In that situation,
what you have to worry
about is how to
place this data that
is being generated so that
you can make sure that
it scales and it
also provides you
low-latency properties,
all of these good things
that you need to do.
So, that's the idea
behind this DataFog,
and in particular what
happens is that there could
be skews in the workload.
Going back to the game
example that you had,
as soon as the game ends,
everybody's leaving the stadium.
So, it is going to
result in a huge amount
of activity around that area,
and in that case,
the Edge infrastructure
here is going to
be oversubscribed.
So, what we have in DataFog
is ways by which we can say,
what is the data that we need
for immediate query answering?
So, these are real-time queries
can be answered by that,
and the older data
can be moved up in
the hierarchy to
ultimately to the Cloud,
and so that's the way we think
about capacity conscious
data replication.
There are details of, again,
on how we do that,
taking both the
spatio-temporal coordinates
of the location of
the data and then
figuring out how
to displays the data in
terms of replication.
So, details of that you can see
in a publication that recently
came on board as well.
So, those are the examples I
have of things that we're
doing in the infrastructure,
but I want to give you
a couple of examples of
applications that might
use autonomous Edge.
So, for this, I'm
going to give you
an example of creating
Space Time Trajectory of
vehicles on the roadways.
Now, the assumption
is that you know
already the layout of
cameras in the roadways
and so in principle might seem
like if I wanted to record
the activity of
all the vehicles all the time,
it seems like a lot of data.
But in practice,
what is happening
is every car starts
its journey somewhere,
ends it's somewhere, right?
So, it's an activity and
the number of
activities is bounded
by traffic conditions and where
you want to go and so on,
and so that's
the intuition behind
how we can do this even
though we want do this
continuously for all the vehicles.
So, the idea is that
the camera that are
attached to Edge nodes
and in a particular roadway,
I sight a particular vehicle,
and I can say this
is the geocoordinate
of this vehicle and this is
the time at which I
saw this vehicle here.
As soon as I know this,
I can communicate to
other cameras that are
downstream from me.
Given the direction of
motion of the vehicle and
the layout of the cameras
in the roadways,
and I can tell
the downstream cameras that,
"Look out for this vehicle."
I'm sending a signature of
the vehicle to look for and it is
the responsibility of
the downstream nodes
to re-identify when that
particular vehicle comes along.
So, when that particular
vehicle comes along,
it can record that, "Well,
I found this vehicle at
the geolocation G_2 and
a particular time T_2.
Once I have that,
once these guys can confirm
that yes, they found it,
then I can actually send
this partial trajectory that I
have to this guy and get
rid of it locally, right?
I don't have to hold it anymore.
So, you can aggregate all of
these trajectories and
keep it together and,
of course, you can say, "Well,
we may not be able to keep
all the trajectories at
one point and you can
do either lazy
aggregation and so on."
We'll talk about
that in a minute.
Also, as you keep on getting
all of these trajectories
accumulated here,
you might say that
some of these are
old trajectories and
recent queries for
recent tracks in which case I can
even push it into the Cloud
and not do that and we can do
lazy trajectory aggregation so
that you can keep the footprint
of storage requirement in
each of the nodes reasonable.
As I said, the storage
is bounded by
the activities that is
at a particular camera,
and that's the reason that it is
something that is scalable
and it can do it.
Again, this is
only a bird's eye view
of what this paper does.
If you're interested, talk to me.
What we are doing right
now is we're working
with campus security folks.
I'm sure that this is something
that most of you have
experienced that every
campus has cameras,
and I asked my security guy,
"What do you do with the camera?"
"Oh, we have a Google map and
we can click on the camera
and look at what is happening.
There is no intelligence."
We asked them what are the use
cases that they
are interested in,
and we can actually track
vehicles in real-time
and then record that.
So that's what we're doing
currently with that.
Another example that
I wanted to give
is in the context
of social sensing,
and what we have done is
we have multiple components
in the application, and again,
deployed it across the continuum
and you can have
network partitions,
and if you have
then you can reconfigure and
resume the operation and
opportunistically we can
communicate when it is possible
using drones or buses that
carry Edge nodes and so on;
we can communicate with that.
This is, again, something that we
have done before and if you're
interested you can look
at this publication.
So, there is a bunch
of ongoing work and I
won't talk about that,
but if you're interested
I can do that because
I've been asked to wrap
up and so I'll wrap up.
So, in the final comment
that I want to make is
that I hope whether it
is propagated or not,
but I hope I have communicated
that we want to make the
Edge as a peer of the Cloud.
Victor articulated and how
this is a disruption that is
coming and in order
to position ourselves
for the disruption,
this is the thing that we
want to be looking
at, okay? Thank you.
>> Same thing anybody have
any initial thoughts on the doc?
>> [inaudible] kind of vision.
The question I would ask,
Satya talks about
Microsoft as a company
that can be trusted with
privacy guarantees.
I was.
>> I can hear.
>> Privacy guarantees
security for data.
I was sort of expecting between
the two talks so far that
somebody would start
to talk a little bit
about the privacy
implications of Edge,
and of course here you are
looking at who might
be driving a car,
where they're driving
to and who's with them.
That's very clearly
in this space.
So, I'm just curious to know what
your thoughts are
about a part of this.
>> That's a very valid concern
so for instance,
when I talked to the campus
security folks they said, well,
are you going to publish these
camera feeds on YouTube?
I said No. I'm just using it for
analysis and then recording it,
and we're not doing
anything more with that.
But absolutely right that
privacy considerations
is super important,
and we have
a very strong group at
Georgia Tech that is
looking at security and
privacy issues and I hope
to partner with them
in terms of looking at
some of those issues.
>> Okay. On that note
thank you very much.
Ken, just one comment I'll
make to your comment is that,
we've been dealing with
traffic cameras quite a bit
and every city deals
with it differently.
Some of them for example Seattle,
just puts it on
the web, you can go and
look at it. Anybody can.
Other places like Belleview
will not put it on the web
and then we have to sort of sign
some sort of agreement with them.
So there is no clarity yet on
how people are dealing with
it because it's policy.
Anyway, beyond that real pleasure
to introduce
Arjmand Samuel to you,
Arjmand, he's a Principal
Program Manager
in the Windows IoT Azure Group.
He is in product but he
has been in research.
He was part of MSR,
in fact he and I worked
together quite a bit on
some projects you might
remember like Hawaii and
then lab of things
which is an IoT thing.
But then he moved on to
the product division
and now he thinks
a lot about IoT and he thinks
about the Edge and in fact,
with encodes owns the direction
in which it takes.
So I wanted him to
share with you,
he has a PhD from Purdue
so among his alumni.
I wanted to ask him
to share with you,
our existing, current vision
of where we are headed with
all this stuff, so Arjmand.
>> Thank you, Victor.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Thank you, Victor,
for the invitation.
I've been working
with a bunch of,
I see very familiar faces,
quite a few, and so I've been
working with the community
for some time.
I moved off to Azure IoT which is
the Azure engineering team
responsible for
IoT about 3 and a half
years back.
I lead the Azure IoT
Edge engineering.
So my team is responsible
for making Edge real and
the one message I bring to
this group here is that
Edge is really real.
There are actual customers and
I'm going to actually
talk about some of those,
there are actual
customers who use Edge,
who see the value in the Edge and
the Cloud and they
marry the two together.
So there's a lot of
momentum that we see out
there and I'm going
to talk about that.
So, when Victor asked me I
should come here I said "what
better thing to do than to
bring in some real scenarios,
some real actual customer
use cases and
talk about some of the challenges
that they see are customers".
Then really ask you,
the community to solve
some of those challenges.
So let's make it real.
I'm going to give
you a little bit
of an introduction into
the IoT patterns that we see.
This is how we right now
see of course the Cloud
is there and when we make
a slide with a Cloud,
the Cloud takes 75 percent
of the space, that's by design.
But as you would also come here.
We look at IoT as things.
These are things
around us there are
things here there are things,
the vehicle is a thing,
smart cities,
manufacturing machines,
robotic arms, they're all things.
Things do two things
they generate
data and they can be actuated,
they can be controlled.
So, these are things.
Another thing we look at it
in three ways is insights.
When these things generate
data there's a lot
of insights that you
can get from the data.
You can understand what is
the state of the machine,
you can understand the state of
the environment in which
the machine is operating,
you can also because
now you have insights,
you can have some actions.
You can do some actions
on the machine on
the thing or you can take
actions on your end,
you can adapt
some processes and so.
So that's how we look at this,
data of course flows as we
see it today from the things
to insights in the Cloud and from
there to actions and then
maybe actions come
back to the Cloud.
But then now if you put
an Edge concept on top of it,
you have- I'll skip this.
You have the same thing,
you have the same insights,
you have the actions
and you of course have
a Cloud gateway but
what you now do
here is you move some of
the insights you get from data,
some of the actions
that you need to do
and you bring it right
there on the thing.
Now your thing the robotic arm,
the huge milling machine,
your car, your smart city,
your environment like
this conference room,
they have become smart
in themselves because
those insights which essentially
is AI machine learning,
parts of those have been
moved and to the thing.
That's how we look
at the Edge because
Edge and the Cloud work together.
Now I won't go over
some of the virtues of
the Cloud and some of
the virtues of the Edge,
only to say that both of
them are important
in their own self.
You cannot do a huge machine
learning training exercise
with tons of data from
distributed nodes coming
and you only need
the Cloud to do that because
of near-infinite resources.
But then at the same time
if you're looking for
near real time latency,
you are looking for
control loops which
can run reliably right next to
the machine you are not
going to send calls
up to the Cloud and wait
for them to come back,
which might not be reliable.
You need those insights,
those AI machine learning
right on that machine.
Now, we can talk a lot
about these these virtues
of the Cloud and the
Edge and how they
sit together and how
they augment each other,
but the way we have done
now coming to what we
have done the product
is to create a consistency
between the Cloud and the Edge.
By consistency we mean
the consistency in
programming models,
consistency in the
application model.
What does that mean?
That means that if there is
a workload that you're
running in the Cloud.
Imagine a Stream Analytics job
which is ingesting tons of data,
analyzing the data and then
coming out with some statistics,
the same application model we
have created for the Edge.
Which has implications
beyond just the model,
which means you can actually move
that same workload without
any change from the Cloud
onto the Edge without
any modifications,
without writing any code
all through configurations.
So that is the consistency,
that is how consistency between
the Cloud programming model and
the application model and
the Edge programming model
and application model helps us.
It has implications
beyond just technology,
it has organizational
implications.
So now if you do not
have this consistency in
the programming model,
you need developers,
you need people who
actually program
the Cloud application and then
you need people who
actually go in and
program the Edge application.
But the consistency and an
infrastructure which allows
you to move workloads from
the Cloud to the Edge,
you do not need
that you just need
Cloud developers who develop
their applications in the Cloud,
make parts of it which they want
or they think or
they optimized to
run on the Edge and simply
configure it that way and
then they can move it back.
So that's really how
we look at the Edge
that is what Azure IoT Edge does.
By the way this is
Azure IoT Edge,
there's also another product
the Edge browser this is not it,
this is Azure IoT Edge
which we're talking about.
Okay so now I'm going to make it
a little bit real
then I'm going to
stop a little bit and
go into some design
principles here.
This is a real customer
that we worked with.
They have a mining operation.
They have spread these
pumps which are spread
around this very
remote locations.
Many of these remote locations
are in the ocean,
they're not even on land.
Then they have one central place
where they're controlling them.
Network connectivity to
these remote locations
is very bad or very expensive.
So they typically would use
satellite connectivity.
They can only get alerts
otherwise it becomes
very expensive.
Also reliability of
operation of this pump is
extremely important
because if it goes
down you lose money you
lose oil which is money.
So this is their world,
there is a pump
here which is going
up and down similar to that one.
The pump has really it's
boiled down to
two values of pressure.
Pressure above the plunger
and pressure below the plunger.
Then this on the X axis is
the position of the pump.
So at all times there is
an envelope of operation
for these two pressures,
the minute it goes
out of scope out of
that envelope this pump
fails and this whole
operation goes down.
Now obviously there is
a requirement for it
to be near real time,
so they need to monitor this,
there's also a requirement
to be predictive.
You cannot wait for
this envelope to be
broken to take some action.
You need to predict when
this would happen so that
it does not break down and
you can do something
about this pump.
You want to do it in offline.
This pump could be
operating in the middle of
the ocean and you do not
have any connectivity
to the Cloud.
Now how they do it is right now,
they would have the pump.
They actually have
some automation they call it,
there's a gateway, there's
a SCADA controller,
there's an HMI right next to it.
Then there's an alert there's
a supervisor sitting
in the central place,
there is an alert
which is generated
when that envelope is broken
and then the supervisor would
send somebody who would
start tweaking the pump,
shutting it down or doing things
which they can do to
mitigate that issue.
So what they have now done and
of course moving that data
up to the Cloud and
training machine learning
and all is expensive,
remember this satellite
connectivity.
So, what they've done here,
right next to
the existing gateway
and the pump controller,
they have deployed
Azure IoT Edge.
This is right now on pumps
on mining operations.
What it allows you to
do is to, first of all,
have some translation between
the protocols that are
happening that are used.
Modbus is the protocol they
use and protocols which
are more IoT-enabled like MQTT.
But the second thing,
most important thing,
you can actually deploy
machine learning
right on the platform
on the pump,
and now you could
be disconnected,
and when that bad thing happens,
you actually can control.
Sorry, you can actually
control this pump
right from there,
you do not need to be
connected to the Cloud.
Now this is a real scenario,
this is what customers use today,
Azure IoT Edge today.
Another one, I just
have a few minutes.
Another one is using
drones for a number of
different operations,
mostly vision video from
drones and there are
a bunch of scenarios.
Infrastructure
inspection is one of
the most popular scenario
that we are seeing today.
There are miles upon miles,
hundreds of miles of
pipeline which is
laid out there and it's
physically not
possible for somebody,
a technician, to go out and
inspect every inch
of the pipeline.
So what they do is,
they've started to do is,
fly drones over those pipelines
and then take video
from the pipeline.
Previously, what they
would do is they
would collect a lot of video,
bring it back to
the base station and
then start analyzing.
That, of course, meant
they had a latency of
a few hours before
they would know
that bad things are
happening there.
So they're using,
and I'm going to go
into the scenario
a little bit more.
Smart agriculture;
there's a lot of work
that has happened
just to understand how
the agriculture operation
is happening,
drones are used there.
Of course, our favorite
scenario which
we like to debate a lot
about is surveillance.
There's a lot of scenarios where,
legitimately, you could
use drones there.
So, Azure IoT Edge can actually
sit on top of a drone.
The drone that it sits
on- We have a
partnership with DJI,
which is a major,
one of the world's biggest
drone manufacturer.
We worked with them.
They put Azure IoT Edge
right on top of
the drone and then through
connectivity with the Cloud,
you can move your machine
learning onto that drone.
Then these cheaper drones,
this is about $1,000,
that's about $15,000.
These cheaper drones, you
actually can set
up a base station.
They do not have
sufficient compute,
more importantly, battery
to support Edge compute.
So, you can actually deploy
it on a base station and then
within that environment you
can do AI and ML and so on.
So, these two are actually
soon they'll have an SDK,
DJI will where you can actually
developers can develop
using Azure IoT Edge to deploy
things onto the drones.
How does the whole thing work?
You have a video camera, which
is a drone video camera.
We have IoT Edge
device on the drone.
This is a little Nvidia chip
that sits there.
On top of it, of course,
in the Cloud, we have IoT Hub,
and you have a bunch of
your smarts AI and
ML in the Cloud.
What you do is you
containerize them,
we use Docker
container technology,
you host it in the Cloud
in a container repo,
you could use Azure Container
Registry or Docker repo.
Then you could move
containers there,
you build a manifest,
you move it onto the drone,
the manifest knows what are
the different components you
need to move down onto the drone.
Then Azure IoT Edge runtime
starts moving those containers
onto that platform.
Then you could be
disconnected as long
as you have the smarts
which are required
for the drone to fly.
You could be connected again,
you could be doing it at scale.
So, the whole value prop here is
to actually allow you to
not deploy one drone,
but to deploy thousands
upon thousands of
drones and keep it updatable.
You have a new machine
learning model,
which you have retrained
based on data that you got,
now you want to update
your drone with a new
machine learning model.
All you do is do a second
version of this container,
push it up there,
update the manifest, and now
you get the new version.
So here are some design
principles that we follow.
Of course, security is one
of the most important ones
that are required for
Edge Computing given
the devices out there.
We have invested quite a lot,
we have created
some partnerships,
quite a few partnership
with Silicon Vendors,
we have already announced,
and NXP microchip.
They actually create
the right security frameworks
for Edge to work.
All of this is Cloud-managed
while it can be disconnected.
But to bootstrap their device,
you need Cloud management
but it is done at scale.
So, we can manage millions of
IoT Edge devices which are
deployed out there
from the Cloud.
We can provision them
with zero-touch,
we can also move configurations
down onto those devices
with zero-touch.
Cross-platform IoT Edge devices,
you know the ones
we sat on top of
the drones are
Windows, can be Linux,
multiple versions of Linux,
as long as the OS
supports containers,
it can actually deploy
Azure IoT Edge.
Portable, we have
a full Dev experience,
CICD pipeline and so on for this.
Then extensible, it's not
only Azure services
that you deploy,
not only Azure machine learning,
not only Azure AI and so on.
It could be your own code,
it could be your own smart AI
that you want to
deploy onto the Edge.
You simply package
it as a container,
put it somewhere, and
then it can be deployed.
Can I finish and then I'll
come to the question?
In fact, what we have done here,
we have created a marketplace
for all of these modules,
we call them modules, all
of these containers to be
discoverable from where you
can deploy onto the Edge.
I'll briefly touch on that.
So, in terms of hardware,
anywhere from
this interactive tier
is something similar
to a Raspberry Pi,
which can host Linux
in containers,
all the way to
accelerate the tiers.
These are FPGA-enabled,
GPU-accelerated hardware.
IoT Edge can exist there.
Here are open source. Azure
IoT Edge is on GitHub.
MIT License totally open source,
you can pick it up
and do whatever
you want to do with it.
It's Moby-based, so Docker
is based on Moby technology,
and that's what it is based on.
We have a marketplace
where you can actually
go in and buy these
or get these modules.
Security intelligence, we have
a bunch of tooling,
different languages.
We have five languages in which
you can actually
write these modules;
C, C#, Java, Node, Python.
You can actually deploy it
in any of these languages.
Since I have a couple
of more minutes,
scale is one of the big
challenges that we face
today, scale of deployment.
These mining operations do
not work in onesies twosies,
they work in thousands
to millions.
Right and they ask for
that kind of scale.
Not just scale of deployment
but scale of management,
scale of state management,
scale of monitoring.
All of that has to be always
at least a million devices
that you think of.
So, that's something that we have
been thinking a lot about.
We provide zero-touch for
millions of devices today.
There's a lot to be done there;
supply chain has to come up,
silicone has to evolve,
and all of that is happening.
Adapting workloads based on
hardware, network, cost,
so all Edge devices
would not be the same,
they will be
different small, big.
So you have to upload,
you have to have
the right modules
which go there. How
do you do that?
There is an optimization
problem in there which
together with Victor,
Steve, we're investigating.
There's a lot of work that
we're doing on security.
When you move Cloud workloads
to Edge devices
deployed out there,
you have to be very
careful with that.
You have to have
the right silicone,
you have to have
the right models.
Operations, I talked
about that but one thing
that has come up again
and again, Edge devices,
when they are deployed even on
these mining operations
are not single vendor,
they're never single vendor.
There is the owner
of the operation,
there's the owner of the pump,
which is different
and it leads to them.
There is the oil,
the entity which has
interest in the oil who's
selling that oil to somebody.
All of them need a slice of
the data and a slice
of that operation,
and all of that has to be part
of our access control models,
part of how we deploy,
and the policies and so on.
So, just a quick overview of
the research challenges VC.
Azure IoT Edge is
open source, GitHub.
Go and play with it,
and hopefully contribute
to it as well.
>> Thank you very much, Arjmand.
>> Thank you.
>> But there was a question.
In the meantime, Lin
can you please set up.
>> So, this looks like
incredibly cool stuff.
So, I'm curious about,
you mentioned
security and a couple
of the challenging issues there,
and I don't want to ask
a long evolved
question about that,
but the question is, is
their simple mental model for
how to think about security
as I extend to the Edge,
and do I have to
trust the hardware?
Do I have to trust
some other third party?
Is Microsoft going to have
some sea of devices that
can be secured or whatever?
>> Sure. So, I didn't
mention I also lead
security for
the forage varieties,
so I can actually talk at length.
Maybe later on, we can do that.
But just to talk
about it quickly,
there is trust that
is in the Cloud,
which obviously you trust more
because we make sure
that it is trusted.
What we do is, we try to
take the trust and
bring it to the device.
How we do it, is through device
identity and attestation.
We identify the device
through hardware means,
so TPM and such,
and then we build trust
with attestation of
firmware and software
that runs on top of it.
This part of it is not
only Microsoft doing it,
we have to have Silicon firmware,
manufacturers, OEMs,
who contribute to it.
To enable that, we have
a certification program.
So, we certify IoT Edge devices,
which conform to this whole
building of trust mechanism.
So, it's not any device.
If you want to be really secure,
you go and get the certified
device to do that.
>> All right. So, I know
there are more I think,
we will see how it goes.
So, thank you so much
again, Arjmand. All right.
So now, hopefully,
you're getting a sense
of different things,
and different problems
that exists,
and your mind's already churning,
and in terms of where we
are in the product world,
where research is and
where we want to be.
The next speaker is
a rockstar, really is.
In fact, the speaker next to
him is not going to speak,
he is also a rockstar.
He's a 2018 rockstar from
SIGMOBILE, and you are?
>> 2014.
>> 2014 rockstar. I'm
not making it up,
there is a rising star award
for those of you who are in
other segues who don't follow
the rockstar thing, so anyway.
Lin is a professor
at Rice University,
he graduated from Princeton.
So, there you go,
another one of your, yeah.
I've known Lin for
a very long time
and he's great. That's it.
>> Thank you. That's
a good summary.
Thank you very much Victor
for the invitation.
It's my pleasure to talk up
a vision Kyle and I shared.
It's a really a joint work.
Although I'm the one speaking,
you can tell who am I,
based on here, and
Victor will also give
a feed point about this.
We can switch to
cheer the bottle,
we're going to talk of 5G.
I tried to point the link
between 5G and Edge,
and what Edge can do for 5G,
and truly we think
that 5G needs Edge.
So, the question, are we ready?
I think 5G is coming.
This is a once a decade
opportunity for us.
I like to joke like my 10-year,
my full professorship all are
based on 3G and 4G, right?
I do PhD, smartphone takeoff
during a year of 4G,
mobices took off of
the Conference flagship,
conference for Sigma wall.
A lot of things happened.
Here's at Microsoft, I
would say Apple and Google
seized the opportunity of
4G in had Android and
iPhone really big.
I'm sorry Microsoft,
Windows phone missed
the opportunity,
but 5G is here.
Whatever Microsoft would do?
What can we do, right?
So, the takeaway is,
there are four takeaway things
that we think we
need software in the 5G
network infrastructure,
because software
is a little fast,
and we should use net softer
eat everything, right?
We should force after
that actually either
telecom infrastructure,
we have to re-think of softwares,
the whole software stack for
efficiency and availability.
Number three, to use Edge
for telecom infrastructure,
and we have the rethink
of its architecture,
we have to think of
a disaggregated architectures,
how to integrate
accelerators into the Edge Cloud.
Number four, once you have 5G,
have the Edge Cloud there,
it's a great opportunity to
think of what the novel,
new things you can do,
a previous not possible
at any services.
I'm a computer engineer,
so I like to summarize
the history of telecom.
I like to think of
the entire history telecom
is using hardware to run
hardware to solve the
spectrum problem,
because hardware is cheap
and getting cheaper,
even post Moore's law.
But in contrast
spectrum is scarce,
and it's determined
by physics is,
you're never going to
more spectrum, right?
Even FCC could open up more,
but still they are
predetermined by physics.
Why is communication is
about throwing resources,
more computation so that you
can use spectrum
more efficiently,
and here showed is
basically massive MIMO,
one of the key technology for 5G.
You could use lot of antenna,
lot of apparental
processing powering,
and the base station,
so that it can serve multiple
clients at the same time,
to increase spectrum
efficiency, proportionally.
If you still think
look at the 5G,
5G essentially is about
using more hard wall,
and to impose spectrum efficiency
and to reduce the latency, right?
Think of a massive
MIMO as example,
think about a small
cell density deployment
is by more Abs,
more infrastructure, and think
about millimeter-wave radios,
it's about Moho, right?
So, we might think Argos is,
i'll see whether the
first one to be able to
actually the massive
first mass of
my research prototype
a number years go.
That set us on a track
to actually experience
the pain of the entire
telecom industry,
is over the past 75 years
we'll have build
three generations of the Argos
massive my prototype.
This is a first generation
and this is the latest one
we deployed on campus after
one million dollars from NSF,
as you see here eye ground.
With the newest
base station like this,
this is just an unit
deployed on top of
roof as research prototype.
This word perhaps first
deployed massive MIMO
network respite.
The good news we got for those
of you who like to use it,
we just got an award from NSF is
going to make this part of
the community infrastructure,
it will be deployed on campus,
the University over time,
so as open access testbed.
But the sounds like
success story,
but I think this is a failure
story to me, looking back.
It took seven years,
three generations one entire PhD,
and we didn't innovate
any algorithm,
any new things, right?
Basically this is
also generation is,
up to the FPGA.
On bigger FPGA become
available more of from Xilinx,
we need the after the board,
and it took seven years.
So, this exemplify the pain
of the technical infrastructure.
Specialized hardware,
special equipment,
lead to slow innovation,
expensive equipment, and
very high costs of ownership,
and capital investment
expenditure.
If you look to history
to launching 1G,
2G, 5G, 4G, 3.
Each G take ten years at least,
can we use software makes
this process faster?
Can we softerize
the technical infrastructure,
bring in low vision?
What do we have seen in
the Mobile Cloud era to
take them in structure?
That's our position today, right?
The 5G's infrastructure
needs a software approach.
As a great opportunity
for Microsoft,
for us researchers working
on the software systems.
I think that
two lessons we learned,
I think from
our experience building
the mass MIMO
base station and also I
think it's also one of
the lessons from the past 4G,
this is rigid appointment.
Is number one is,
software innovates a
faster, we talked about it.
We should maximize the software,
and minimize the yields
a specialized equipment.
Number two, I think is
resource integrations
about, I will talk
on this points.
By resourcing to integration,
if you look to this base station,
and look at our Argos
base-station is a good example,
is all the resources,
RF actuator,
and hardware, and software
both integrate base station.
In this particular case,
they're integrating
this board which has FPG,
and memory, and software stack
everything in it, right?
So, direct me to
Verso Technology evolution,
because FPG actuators, soft wall,
and RF, they have a different
pace of innovation, right?
Some are faster but
because you are putting
the same board,
the same base station,
you have to wait for
the slowest current update,
update the whole thing, right?
It's impossible inter-cell
resource sharing,
because each of the base station
serve just the reals
or inter-cell.
When you don't have
many users, but your resource,
your computation
resource there it's
width is sitting there idle.
Number three is, when you try to
coordinate two cells to
base stations is become
difficult because you we
have very high throughput
between them to coordinate.
What we argue is,
when you have disaggregated
radio access,
almost like what's
happening in datacenter,
we need to have this resource
desegregating data centers.
Each base station should
only have RF, perhaps ADC,
the IQ samples to a heterogenous,
the surrogate local data center.
We're the competition will
be acceleration or software.
With this architecture,
we will be able to
independently evolve
each of this technology,
and we'd be able to
consolidate resource
bitumen in cells,
and we should be able to
very easily deploy manage
any services software
just to the Edge, right?
For example,
localization services
now could be, in a past,
you have to change
each base station,
now you can just put on a piece
of software in the Edge.
If you want to do for example,
you could also use the software
to handle dense deployment.
This is an example
from Carl's group.
You can have very cheap
access point,
one dense equipment and
a link to Edge
server in software,
and you can handle them morbidity
and reliability in software,
and also can leverage
the property of the propagation,
the channel to input
enhances a support.
This actually is a
how it's deploy.
This is in Princeton campus,
that's a [inaudible] in canvas,
the white blocks are
the axis ones deployed
there, very cheap,
and they are linked to a server
which runs the software
that handle,
switch the link is
switching between
these different access points
to deal with
the past fading problem.
Blue is downlink
and then the green
that uplink and everything's
done in your software.
Another example, this is
a work Victor Klemper
Pascal and Giovanni
Paul from Paris.
This is how can you use
your phone to help each other
recognize where
other available parking space
in a busy city, right?
You just use your phone,
the phone running
real time cars localization,
recognition area with them.
Some of the logic we're
running in the Edge,
and users can share
information and help
each other find a way
out of the parking space.
This also goes back
something while I was on
sabbatical was Victor Globe
of six years ago now.
Wow, time flies.
Six years ago when a lot of
wearable devices showed
up like Google Glass,
we had this vision of
Continuous mobile vision,
that the Cloud,
your personal computer always
see what you see, right?
Therefore, they can do a lot of
interesting things for you.
We actually bought a bunch
of Google Glass and
run software there and the effect
is it's going to kill
the battery in 20 minutes,
and also it's going to
burn your skin quickly.
I think the ways the Edge Cloud,
where is a short
latency promise by 5G,
and you can really move a lot of
computation to the Edge so
that your wearable could
stay cool and friendly.
So, I think important challenges
for doing these things
in software,
move things to the
baseband processor to the Edge.
We have heard a story of
Cloud, [inaudible] years ago,
but that didn't take off but
one of the key challenge
is occurring
by inside information from
Huawei is the efficiency
is terrible.
Running baseband processor in
software in the Edge server.
Reliability is also
questionable compared
to traditional
specialized equipment.
So, to enable software hit
to the 5G infrastructure,
I think it's very important to
rethink about software stack,
and how can make it efficient?
How to make it as available
as like a big public call?
So, one of the solutions
softly efficiencies is
your accelerator for
example cows go by
the show the bios GPUs,
you actually can improve
the efficiency by many folds,
20 times for example.
This could be network
integrated into
the Edge center and to
enable you to update
your accelerator and
CPU's independently.
Right?
Now, I think to Rethink
the software stack for
efficient availability.
I am going to say something
very controversial,
I think there's a lot
of low-hanging fruit,
but I think after you have
optimized for everything,
then you will realize
the Linux operating system,
having a study Windows kernels,
I cannot say about Windows,
but Linux actually would
eventually become
the bottleneck for
efficiency availability
if we would like
to clarify the
telecom instructor,
we need a new software stack.
We need a new kernel.
The reason is very simple
because it use unsafe language
therefore there lot
of run-time checks.
So, you wouldn't be able to
run software efficiently.
Number two, Linux operating
system have a very
weaker modularization.
To update one module,
you often have to hoard
the whole system.
So, I like this graph.
Also from Microsoft,
Gain Hunt and Jim Morris
a number years ago they had
this project called Singularity.
Singularity vision is
to say hey make sure
the correctness of software at
a compile-time and
implantation time.
Don't do it at run-time.
Linux and C basically you force
correctness of run-time which
is like the airport
security check.
Right? Every time you go to
the airport they scan you.
Right? We really need
a software stack like TSA Pre.
Basically you check
the correctness offline,
intrinsically and when they're
wrong just run fast it will run.
Right? So, that's one effort
going on in my group.
We're building
a new operating system,
run-time composite
operating using
Rust intended for
use in the Edge.
Again, it has some rice,
I think I convinced
you 5G is really opportunity for
software people
into software Play
and there's a lot of
opportunity for Edge Cloud
there to support the 5G
infrastructure. Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
Okay. First, thank you
very much for your
great presentations and
giving your own point
of view on this.
I always sort of
when Bang presented you
had a slide in there
where you sort of talked
about some of
the assumptions and one of
the assumptions you had
was battery energy,
but then as you look at
some of the other talks,
except for the drone case,
that was not the assumption.
So, what that means is that,
and you will also
encounter this which is,
people will have
different definitions of Edge,
what it is or Edge Clouds or
even Fog or Cloud lattes
and we'll have a very
different definitions of it.
That just sort of shows
that we are constantly
evolving and try
to make it more crisper in
our own head as to what it is.
Now, one thing that you guys
did not talk about,
which I see as
emerging very recently
in fact Microsoft announced
something and then I
heard Google announced
something and I believe
Amazon also has
that is specialized hardware
for the Edge itself.
So, what I have in mind,
what I'm thinking about
is this notion of
having PC or Server Rack with
some specialized hardware.
What are your initial thoughts on
that specialized
hardware existence?
Anybody can take that and
you guys have the mic, right?
>> Yes. I think
it's about how it should
be part of architecture.
I think it's smartness is
the dog burgers using FPGA
datacenters is a good example.
FPGA is not the whole thing,
but part of architecture.
I think in the 5G infrastructure
we would try to
software as a codified.
I think using FPGA,
you should bring FPGA
as part of architecture
instead of have everything in
FPGA is special and how it work.
I think you should
select the way you
use them for the critical paths
for example the data plan.
>> So, let me, I let you
speak Kyle and
the rest of you too.
So, just to sort be
more, even more crisp.
There's lot of thoughts about
Machine Learning on the Edge.
Like there's a debate on how
much you can do in the Edge,
how much you can do Cloud, you'd
shrink the models to
put it on the Edge,
but when you have
specialized hardware
that tends to open up
more avenues to do more stuff
and so that's kind
of what I'm seeing.
So, for 5G I understand that
but any other thoughts?
>> Can I take that?
>> Yeah, please.
>> So, I think there's
a place for both.
There's a place for
general purpose
hardware CPU
based compute as well as
very specialized hardware like
GPU acceleration and
FPGA acceleration.
In the Edge world, again
worth loads tend to be both.
But for workloads like
machine learning and
very specialized AI,
yes FPGA is an avenue,
GPUs are avenue.
We already have
brainwave which we
announced a few months back,
which allows you to
download your ML into
your hardware which has FPGA and
then it fully uses the FPGA.
So, that's brainwave,
it's already announced.
We also have a bunch of
collaborations on
cameras with GPUs,
Qualcomm is one of our partners
where we enable the GPUs to be
used on the camera for
acceleration of
frame detection and so on.
That's all at the
Edge doing that.
So, yes, there's
a place for both,
but I think in the end game,
it won't be any one of those.
I think it will always
be a combination to do.
>> So since my core research is
really in optimization
algorithms,
so I hasten to comment
too much on hardware,
but I just want to quickly
point out two things.
One is that, I think it was
Ken who asked about security.
I have this uninformed
unbiased opinion
that on the Edge of
the hardware-based
security probably
isn't much likely to trust.
Now, as to the second one is that
Microsoft is moving fast and
so are some of
the other companies.
So some of these are not
technologically driven per
se but really is trying to tip
the balance of power in
industry food chain.
Sometimes, having
specialized hardware
may or may not be
actually of use in
a particular domain
but a lot of companies
certainly feel that if I
don't do something
along those lines,
I'll be left in the dust as
the balance of power shifts
with the rise of the Edge.
>> I see.
>> A very interesting
observation.
There's some truth to that.
>> To add to all of this,
think about wireless networks.
We're seeing the limiting factor,
especially with the 5G
technologies,60 gigahertz,
small cells massive
MIMO especially,
limiting factor shifting
from what we do in
the wireless design to
the computational power behind
the wireless algorithms.
So computation is becoming
the bottleneck and
specialized hardware
is allowing us to be
more parallel in
the processing that we do
behind the wireless
algorithms for the Edge.
So it's going to
play a huge role.
GPUs and FPGAs in
base stations and on the Edge.
>> Let me add to this point.
In our own experience in our lab,
similar to what you were
saying about the Azure Edge.
We built a cluster
of Raspberry PIs to
serve as a Fog node and as
I mentioned in my talk,
we want to create the ecosystem
at the Edge, similar
to the Cloud.
So we brought pub-sub
systems like Kafka and
storage system like Ascended
to run on the Edge.
Then we were doing
these camera processing
that I was talking about and
the limitation is
how many cameras frames
per second that you can do,
even if you have a cluster
of Raspberry PIs.
We are limited by that.
So at that point,
you have to include some
additional capabilities like
Nvidia boards in order to
do some of the image
processing faster.
So there is an opportunity
to sort of integrate.
For the mundane stuff,
you can use
off-the-shelf components
but for more
specialized processing,
you may need to incorporate
additional smarts in it.
>> So I would add to that.
I think specialized hardware
is all all about
nonrecurring engineering
cost, right?
You need a massive quantity
of the market to amortize
a nonrecurring engineering cost.
You need to be lumber
to amortize that.
So otherwise, it doesn't make
sense economically to make
[inaudible] just for machinery.
>> So your point is that you need
a lot of Edges for specialized
hardware to take off.
>> Right. Use the same hardware.
The same hardware will
require a lot of deployments,
a lot of devices to use and to
amortize in our [inaudible].
>> Right, so I would have
a follow up question
on but I will not.
The follow up question
will be something like
what kind of hardware
would you bet on?
But let's table that because
I have a bunch of
other things to ask.
So I want to ask Kishore set
up on another vision, right?
So he said our vision which
was about Cloud being
or Edge being parallel
to the Cloud.
Many of you actually
articulated a different vision
where the Cloud and
Edge play together.
Cloud is absolutely necessary
and the Edge is necessary.
So for those of you
who did not play
and not claim the vision
that [inaudible] did,
I want to see what your reaction
was to what he was saying.
Please.
>> I like the vision a lot.
There is a distinction between
the Edge using the Cloud
versus the Edge becoming
the Cloud or replacing
some of what Cloud can do.
I want to highlight
that sometimes,
that word Cloud can also like
word Edge and Fog be
used in multiple ways.
So one particular example is,
this is regarding
a particular startup that I
founded called DataMe and
details doesn't matter.
But it turns out that
when we try to do
billing and the bite
counting in an LTE network,
if you do it in the core network,
which can be drawn
with a big Cloud
occupying 75 percent
of the slide,
then A is expensive,
B is privacy intruding,
and C is slow like
24 hours later,
the Internet operator
can tell you something
about the pricing policies.
So if you want to
innovate pricing,
you've got to first
innovate doing
that in the Edge like mount
the end-user devices.
Maybe for example, to detect
the peak valley condition of
LTE cell turns out that you don't
need to rely on the LTE core,
you can actually do some
of that on the devices.
But the point is that
actually is echoing
Kish respond, right?
That is an example of the
Edge becoming the Cloud,
not just using the Cloud.
However, to do that really
efficiently you can't
rely 100 percent in
that startups case on
all the devices doing
them autonomously.
So we actually had
a little controller in
the other kind of Cloud
in the Azure or Amazon,
if that doesn't trigger
some fire alarm here.
In that Cloud, it's not
the LTE core Cloud.
It's a different kind of Cloud
and put a little provision the
controller to enhance
the efficiency
coordinating the mobile devices.
So we still want that kind
of Cloud even though this is
literally killing a function
and replacing it
of another Cloud.
So this particular example,
this worked out then we have
60 million users in the world
using this product right now,
but it both echoes
the point that Edge
can replace Cloud or
be on equal footing,
but also highlights
the point that it
still doesn't hurt to
have some form of Cloud.
>> I would disagree
a little bit there.
You still need the Cloud.
I'll tell you what
are the scenarios
in which you actually need
a Cloud to bootstrap
your Edge devices. This
is how we do that.
One of them is security
or more precisely, trust.
When you have all of
your devices which now you
call your Cloud distributed,
how do you build
trust amongst them?
Where is your center of trust?
So Cloud gives you
a convenient way of saying,
"Okay, trust is in the Cloud."
From there, I can actually
start trusting software,
do attestations,
trust the hardware and then
I can start deploying these.
So essentially, there's
a master-slave relationship
in terms of trust
there. That's one.
Second is availability or
high availability scenarios which
require coordination amongst
distributed compute nodes.
One way, of course, is that each
one of those nodes
talk to each other,
do election and so on,
but then you still
need some way of
understanding that these nodes
are distributed widely.
How do you coordinate
between them?
So you need some place
where they all come down
to and Cloud would
allow you to do that.
So, and of course, the final
thing here is how would
you manage a very large data
set? You could do that.
You could create little nodes
with Raspberry Pis,
put little data in all of
them and start coordinating.
But it's a huge
data problem then.
Rather than going to the Cloud,
putting all your data and data
doing machine learning there
because you have almost
infinite compute and
resources there,
and then moving it influence
down to those Edge nodes.
So while I do see Edge becoming
more and more powerful,
Edge supporting
so many more scenarios but I
still see there's a place for
the Cloud in there for security.
>> I'd like to add something that
has not been said by anybody yet.
So, if you go to
first principles of Cloud,
part of it was that I sell shoes,
I don't want my IT department,
I wanted somebody else to
take care of the whole thing,
and I'll just write you a check.
All your machines,
all the upgrades,
all the other good stuff has
to happen at somewhere else.
I don't have to. I can
go and sell shoes.
That's like I was one of
the big value
proposition for Cloud.
You didn't have to
worry about hardware.
worry about software,
you didn't have to
worry about management.
It was a computing resource
available to you.
So I think, in the Edge work,
you're going to need
something like that.
You can't, I mean, if you build
a system which is completely
separate from that,
you actually back to
the old world where you're
now back to you having
an old IT department,
back to having all these guys
who are trying to
deal with the Edge Cloud.
>> Can I?
>> Yeah, please.
>> So I just want
to be sure that I
wasn't articulating that
we get rid of the Cloud.
All I was saying was that
we want to put the Edge on
an equal footing with
the Cloud and there are
applications in which
that is super important.
So if you think of
what connected vehicles,
the latency property
suggests that you
want these kind of communication
to happen very quickly
with the Edge.
On the other hand, if all
that I'm interested is
knowing the density of cars
in a particular roadway,
I can send all this
information to the Cloud,
process it offline,
no problem with that.
So in that sense, there's
a coexistence that
is super important.
I think Cloud can play
a huge role exactly
what Arjmand was
saying in terms of
management of the resources.
For instance, in the sense of
the social sensing application,
if politicians
happened recognizing
that partitions happened
and reform really
architecting the
application components
so that you can continue
the application is
something that you would
expect to happen in a central
fashion from the Cloud.
So management functions
are super important.
Trust is super important
and those are things that are
going to come from there.
One more thing I
want to add which
you alluded to at the beginning
when you introduced me,
in affluent communities we
take Cloud for granted.
Everything that we do less in
the Cloud in
affluent communities.
Georgia Tech is located in
midtown Georgia, midtown Atlanta,
and just across
the northside drive
there is an impoverished area,
economically depressed area.
Aspirations of the people
are exactly the
same as aspirations of people in
affluent communities but
they don't have access to
the information and services
that we take for granted.
So one of the things
that I'm hoping is that
this Edge infrastructure
can actually
help in addressing
the digital divide
better than what
Cloud is doing today.
>> Yeah, that's great. I'm going
to ask you one last question.
We'll be five minutes
over because
we started five minutes late.
You guys think if you want to ask
some questions while I'm asking
this particular question.
So, I think to Carlin,
you guys, I thought that's
a pretty compelling story
that you've put together.
I also agree that
the rate of innovation
in 5G and telco has
been substandard.
It is way less than
what the IT does,
and part of it is because
they're calcified
because of the architectures
that they've created,
and are not able to, they're very
worried about switching anything.
So, the vision that you
are painting here is
that "Get out of
the hardware business
to the extent possible,
do everything in software."
The thing you didn't say,
but it's implied in there
is take the IP network,
don't use your own stack,
and you can do pretty
much everything
you want to do after that.
Then, he painted that
Edge is important.
So, the question to you
and actually to others is,
as you think about the doc
that these guys gave,
what is your opinion
about the doc?
But, the question to you
is, this sort of thing
was tried in China, right?
There was this big project
called C-RAN,
Cloud-RAN, where
the ideas were same.
They said they didn't
want to be held
responsible for all the standards
that take forever to do,
so let's take all the signals,
bring it back to the Cloud,
we'll compute it,
and we give it back,
and it's all, but that was
about several years ago.
I don't know what
the state now is.
What did they do wrong,
if at all, versus what
you're seeing now?
>> That's a great
question. I actually
cannot touch on C-RAN
while we're giving a talk.
I think C-RAN's
the right direction.
Centralized, share, consolidated
and using software,
but I think, as far
as I understood,
from people I know
from Huawei and
the equipment vendor is
the electricity bill.
It's just too high. When
you run things in software,
the base station today are
macrocell base station
already cost you a quarter
million dollars a year,
just for electricity bill.
But, now if you move
the processing to software,
and that's just a ten-folds
reduction scenarios,
that I think if we would like to
qualify the telecom
infrastructure,
we have to make
the software efficiency get
close to a specialized equipment
that had multiple routes,
for example, rethink
the software stack use
the accelerators as part
of architecture, I think.
So, yeah, we have to solve
this harder problem.
>> I see. So, you're saying we
have to solve, I was thinking of,
is there some magic to
the new architectural thinking
of saying we got to
have the Edge here,
and that will make the problem,
so if it's the lex b problem,
it'll actually be less
because we're doing this.
>> So, let me try to respond.
It's a hard question to answer,
but let me try to
respond to one source of
magic is how we can
co-design classical
network protocols
that we know with
this new architecture,
this new Edge Cloud architecture,
co-design of the protocols.
So, for example, co-designing
the Wi-Fi reliable transmission
with multiple roadside hotspots,
co-designing in the cellular
context and the 5G context,
co-designing the
base station LTE protocols
with the new architecture.
That's going to be
the interesting
intellectual challenges
going forward.
>> Right. Did you guys have
a comment or simply move on?
>> I'll just make a meta-comment,
not just specific
to this question.
What I see right now is
a huge gap or lack
of standards for
Edge computing generally.
I know OpenFog is
doing a lot there,
whatever you call that,
but the name itself,
but there is a lot of need for
different communities to come
together and work on standards,
and there are
disparate standards.
The security standards
we use today
were developed and
designed for IT world,
and now we're trying to put
them into the IoT world.
The whole container
standardization
was not done for IoT devices.
It was done for
several class devices,
and we're trying to
simply reuse that too.
So, there's an opportunity there,
not just in this area,
but all of the Edge,
the whole stack, with
standardization, could help a lot.
>> Okay, great. Is
there a question
from the audience? Yeah.
>> So, I thought that's
a really interesting panel,
and I guess
my question relates to
Azure IoT more than
the rest of the work.
Answers from anybody.
Personally, I believe
that we're going to have
an Edge that's mostly
connected to the Cloud,
but that because of
these real-time and
hardware pressures
that the OS and
system infrastructure
has to change because
the traditional Azure is
a very long stack from
external events to
backend processing.
We heard comments about that.
Here we're talking about
strongly consistent
real-time reactions
with hardware in the loop,
which were all things that
really are quite different from
Elsin's vision of what
Azure's fabric looks like.
The hardware, for example,
in the loop is not really
accessible to me as
a client using Azure.
It's accessible to me
through Azure Services,
and they're mostly
using their hardware
somewhere deeper in the Cloud.
So, I'm wondering how you see
the Azure IoT evolving as
an operating system or as
a software ecosystem that
enables the customer
to directly leverage,
for example, RDMA
into FPGA clusters.
These are things which
Microsoft talks
about all the time,
but there's no doubt that
they are not viewed as
end-user technologies right now.
>> I agree with that.
I mean there's, again, gaps.
We're talking about some of
the gap, and you're right.
In the data center,
there's multiple levels of
indirection before
you hit the hardware,
so layers upon layers
and our customers really
get the highest level of
layer if they want,
and they can go down.
For the Edge, we have tried to
create some layering there,
which is more friendly to
the developer and hence the user,
which is through
containers, right?
So if he can move
containers around which
tends to be contained
in that way,
we can give some level of
abstraction on top of hardware.
But, still, you're right.
At the end of the day,
the customer who's deploying
an Edge device has to be
involved in the maintenance
of the hardware,
the management of
the operating system,
and anything above that,
including the container
management system.
So, I believe these
are early days.
They were still, you're right,
there probably is
an opportunity to
create an operating
system all up,
which abstracts all of that for
our developer as
well as the user,
but I don't think we
are there right now.
>> Yeah, I was going to just make
a little comment again,
just stayed tuned.
So, the things you bring up are
actually on our mind as well,
and what you see today is
a very early version of VR
and where we want to go.
So, anyway, I have been asked to
cut this off, so we will.
Once again, let's thank
our panelists and our speakers.
Thank you very much
for attending,
and let's the conversations
continue. Thank you very much.